[Aplausos]
por onde eu ando eu tenho escutado uma
mesma frase
as crianças não brincam mais já virou
quase até um mantra da vida moderna mas
eu me pergunto sei lá não brincam mesmo
eu passei dois anos na estrada
percorrendo o brasil no projeto
território do brincar em companhia do
meu marido
o documentarista david luiz ex e os
nossos dois filhos pra gente pesquisar
chegar mais perto e registrar o flock
brinca então as nossas crianças
mas por onde a gente passava a gente era
recebido por os adultos que infelizmente
repetiram o mesmo mantra da vida moderna
podia ser uma pequena comunidade
quilombola no maranhão tipo mil
habitantes um vilarejo litoral do ceará
os adultos eram unânimes não aqui as
crianças não brincam mais nossa gente
ficou assustado mas se a gente tivesse
acreditado nisso a gente teria tido um
enorme problema porque o que a gente
estava querendo era registrar o lado o
potente da infância tipo lado cheio do
copo ou como o pesquisador ganho de
piorski que tanto nos ajuda a olhar
profundamente esse trabalho eles noites
ele nos diz é que é pra gente focar na
saúde do brincar naquilo que há mais
vivo na experiência das crianças
sabe quem nos salvou as crianças é claro
o enorme não que a gente recebia dos
adultos era rapidamente transformado em
um gigantesco sim das crianças
cada pequeno lugar que a gente chegava
nosso primeiro contato com eles era
mostrando filmes de curtas metragens que
a gente havia feito em comunidades
anteriores tinha menino que nem se
aguentava acabar o filme saia correndo
para casa buscar alguma coisa diz assim
olha eu sei fazer isso eu sei brincar
disso então acho que a primeira coisa
que a gente aprendeu com o território de
brincar é que era preciso lapidar um
pouquinho mais o nosso olhar pra gente
conseguir enxergar o que brincam às
crianças
estou aí a céu aberto fazendo coisas
incríveis mas o nosso foco era olhar um
gesto
o que será que nos dizem os gestos das
brincadeiras o que eles nos revelam o
que está por trás do gesto
essa era uma opção nós e aí vamos ver
alguns exemplos das coisas que a gente
conheceu das crianças brincando por
exemplo isso crianças brincando com a
beleza
o belo ele é uma busca do ser humano e
as crianças elas já sabem isso a gente
não precisa ensinar a elas as crianças
querem a beleza elas buscam isso ea
gente vai lapidando o olhar e vai
entendendo o que isso significa
esse manuseio delicado das pontas dos
dedos que vão lá manuseando a flor a
lama
uma vez uma escola aqui em são paulo me
convidou
pra responder perguntas de crianças de
mais ou menos 56 anos sobre essas fotos
aqui que até já virar um livro
as crianças das três salas
elas me perguntaram uma mesma coisa que
eu fiquei 1 ou o que é isso
as crianças falaram assim mas renata
aonde que essas crianças elas
encontraram terra para brincar tem uma
autora que eu estou encantada por ela
neste momento ela chama de grife
ela tem um livro que chama que nesse
livro ela fala pra gente que as crianças
na geração atual
elas estão sofrendo de um mais novo
abandono
o distanciamento da terra mãe do latim
mater a matéria natural
então quando a gente vê esses pratinhos
de comida quando a gente vai olhar
dentro de si jeff as crianças nos
revelam que é urgente a gente plantar
mais flores para serem vividas por elas
que é urgente a gente oferecer pra elas
um cantinho de terra para que elas
cresçam enraizadas dentro da sua própria
natureza
mais adiante a gente conheceu tantas e
tantas brincadeiras entre elas essa aqui
aqui gesto é pra cima é um verdadeiro
combate às forças da gravidade é uma
brincadeira de quem quer crescer de quem
quer ser grande o desafio seguinte é
conseguir entrar no rio
timo no pulso certo do brincar e aí o
desafio principal desse jogo ajustar o
seu gesto na beleza do gesto belo não
tem pra ninguém
o jogo está ganho mas não é sente uma
beleza padrão é uma beleza que expressa
a potência de cada um
mas será que olhar para a potência do
outro é fácil
será que quando a gente enxerga a
potência do outro muitas vezes também a
gente não se depara com a nossa própria
impotência
será que no nosso dia a dia a gente está
sendo convidado a se expressar
livremente pela própria potência
eu vejo isso nessas crianças se consegue
ver essas são brincadeiras universais
elas nos une muito mais do que nos
separa
elas nos conectam com uma memória
coletiva como se existisse um grande rio
lá no fundo onde todos nós todos nós
vamos beber lá na mesma fonte
quando a gente caminha mais adiante a
gente ver crianças brincando
intensamente com meios de transporte
carros barcos aviões e três helicópteros
motocicletas entra dentro desse gesto é
o gesto do ir dos seguir a saga dos
seguir a sua própria jornada em suas
crianças estão fazendo quando estão
brincando disso
quando a gente vê esses meninos que faça
o seu próprio brinquedo
a gente vê que mesmo aquele mais
simplesinho algo que ele que é feito com
uma latinha puxado com arame esse
brinquedo tem movimento
ele anda ele segue adiante e é isso que
estão buscando essas crianças ir adiante
seguir o seu próprio caminho
os barcos eles pedem simetria eles pedem
leveza eles pedem precisam é um
verdadeiro diálogo entre água e ar barco
feito por criança tem que navegar
se não eles não trazem a verdade que o
brinquedo tem q já viram criança que diz
assim mas isso é verdade verdadeira
a criança tem total noção dessa
distinção entre o que é uma verdade na
verdade verdadeira quando elas estão
brincando
elas estão se ajeitando dentro das
verdades do mundo a isso que elas querem
na verdade de si mesmas
será que a gente está deixando com que
elas vivam a sua verdade porque pra isso
elas precisam de tempo
elas precisam de liberdade
elas precisam de ócio
elas precisam disso para exercitar esse
músculo do desejo que faz com que a
gente possa se escutar a nós mesmos a
saber né a sabemos quem somos
brincar até ver com isso quem eu sou
porque sem isso elas crescem acreditando
que vai sempre ter alguém
de fora dizendo que quer pra fazer e
ainda pior
dizendo que que é pra elas desejarem
eu acho que a maior loucura é a gente
acreditar que a loucura do outro é que
várias ser vivida e é isso que a gente
faz se a gente não dá para as nossas
crianças
esse respiro de vida para se escutar
quem elas são
brincar é ser quem eu sou
enquanto a gente tiver dizendo
reforçando esse mantra
a gente não está assumindo que queremos
uma sociedade livre que se expresse
livremente
vamos estar construindo seres mais
fracos mas manipuláveis
a gente vai para acreditando que existe
um suposto vazio na infância e que a
gente adultos que precisamos preencher
esse vazio já que é um vazio né
crianças não sabem nada elas esvaziadas
então a gente tem que preencher como a
gente faz isso há gente a cola elas com
o consumo de objetos atividades
informações estímulos e ou não tem como
escutar si mesmo
não tem como respirar quem o sul há de
novo a dgrhe fi nos coloca que criança
que só tem brinquedo industrializado
para brincar
elas têm um vão por dentro que não se
pode ser suprimido pelo seu próprio
brincar pelo seu próprio imaginar
e aí elas viram verdadeiros pedintes da
indústria do entretenimento
uma vez eu conheci um menino
em roraima o menino aptiana que sabia
fazer um pião da semente do tucumã super
difícil de fazer
depois a gente passou horas jogando o
peão é no dia seguinte quando eu passei
pelo jogo onde a gente tinha jogado eu
encontrei o peão da menina no chão e eu
falei nossa idéia é ficar super
preocupado procurando o seu brinquedo
aí eu peguei o peão e limpei assim foi
no rio sai atrás dele disse
aqui tá se o peão se deve estar
procurando esse menino ele me disse uma
coisa que eu não quis que se ele olhou
pra mim com uma cara assustada e falou
assim renata a brincadeira já acabou
foi embora e o lar campeão na mão pra
este menino
o brinquedo só faz sentido quando a
brincadeira tá viva
caçá peão passar sementes construiu o
peão jogar
é tudo parte do mesmo ciclo depois
aquela semente volta a ser floresta e
fecha o ciclo do brincar e quando a
gente vê crianças construindo os seus
próprios brinquedos
a gente percebe vários mecanismos que
elas já têm de aprendizado criança
quando constrói brinquedo se utiliza do
corpo inteiro pra isso da língua até o
ponta dos pés
elas buscam viver os diferentes desafios
que os mais diversos materiais oferecem
para elas e elas aprendem a manusear
ferramentas como serrotes facões
martelos porque elas têm ao lado dela
adultos que sabem fazer e aí numa
observação bastante silenciosa sem dizer
nada
elas ficam perto dessas pessoas que
sabem fazer
e assim como de corpo pra corpo
elas vão adquirindo como que por osmose
novas habilidades
elas vão adquirindo autonomia o
aprendizado se dá pelos sentidos pelo
olhar pelo escutar pelo pegar pela
experiência vivida e isso as crianças já
sabem a gente não precisa ensinar isso
pra ela ela já vivem isso mas elas vivem
isso de uma forma espontânea de uma
forma livre
então se a gente quer assumir essa
sociedade que pode se expressar
livremente pela sua própria potência
a gente precisa acreditar efetivamente
no que fazem as crianças a gente precisa
acreditar na infância
o brincar ele é um ato de resistência
pela vida é essencial uma senhora no
recôncavo baiano
quando a gente mostrou pra ela imagens
das crianças da sua própria comunidade
brincando ela disse assim nossa
isso parece um espelho de oxum que vem
mostrar pra gente
a beleza que somos escutar e olhar a
brincadeira livre espontânea das
crianças nos revela a beleza que somos
como seres humanos
é isso que o território do brincar tem
tentado fazer e como nos diz
a querida pesquisadora lydia hortélio
haverá um dia em que a revolução virá
pelas crianças e eu quero estar lá pra
ver
obrigado
[Aplausos]